Speaker 1: Let's get right into some interesting
posts from The David Pakman Show Subrata. Remember
that you can participate in the discussions at
David Pakman dotcom slash Reddit. Nearly 35000
of our viewers and listeners are
subscribed free to the sub Reddit
David Pakman dot com slash Reddit. A
couple of interesting posts I spotted
William McAdoo posted this morning.
Did or know yesterday David was right
about Tulsi Gabbard being a phony and links to a
piece done by our friends over at the Young Turks
about Tulsi Gabbard defending drone usage.
To Tucker Carlson. You know, I have to admit,
I completely forgot about Tulsi Gabbard. It's
actually crazy how, you know, she was polling
one to three percent, but there was a movement
that was very strongly behind her that wouldn't
allow any criticism of Tulsi Gabbard and said she
is really the progressive and all this different
stuff. She clearly was not. She just disappeared,
left Congress, etc.. And then now all of a sudden
she's back and she's criticizing Joe Biden and
she's defending drones and she's doing all sorts
of very strange things. I my advice is just don't
worry about Tulsi Gabbard. I find her. I couldn't
find her less relevant, truly. And it's crazy.
Oh, actually, someone even posted this to the
sub Reddit. They said it's crazy because Biden is
literally more progressive than she is. There's no
question about it. There was nothing the entire
Towsley thing was just a scam. And I'm glad that
there are more people now. Understanding that they
may have fallen for a scam, but it's a very good
thing that Tulsi has basically disappeared other
than, I guess, appearing on Fox News and tweeting
another post from user king Vercingetorix. I
hope I'm pronouncing that correctly, which says,
covid has killed about as many Americans as the
1918 to 1919 flu, with the additional caveat
that many people died from secondary bacterial
infections during the 1918 flu pandemic because
that was that was the situation back then. And
that when you account for that, in a sense,
covid itself has killed more. And yet we
continue to see a large portion of this
population in the United States that just doesn't
want to take it seriously, even to this day. And,
you know, at some point they're going to be
bailed out. That's the crazy thing. Like,
most people will survive assuming covid doesn't,
you know, mutate into something far more deadly,
which is not expected to happen. Most
people will survive. And no matter when
it happens, they will say, we told you so. We told
you we never had to actually do anything. But,
yeah, the flu comparison number is now
becoming relevant and much discussed topic.
And then lastly, a critique of this deferral
that's taking place to the Senate parliamentarian
with a post called The Most Powerful Office in
the Nation. The parliamentarian is exerting its
power again, writing, Senators Chuck Schumer
and Dick Durbin are beating the drums again.
That the almighty nameless overlords simply
referred to as the parliamentarian is putting a
stop to all the good things the lovable Democrats
want to do. There's absolutely nothing they can
do. It's like trying to beat Zeno's with all the
Infinity Stones. OK, seriously, I can't believe
they're trying this boldface lie again. It's very
clearly just an excuse to renege on their promise.
David Sirota posted on Twitter. Not only can
Chuck Schumer replace the parliamentarian,
Kamala Harris can overrule. The
parliamentarian daily poster was
one of the only outlets to report this back
during the fifteen dollar minimum wage fight,
because apparently nobody is allowed to mention
this fact. Yeah, I, I, I think the only way to
say it is I'm pretty sick of the parliamentarian
stuff. The parliamentarian can be overruled,
the parliamentarian can be replaced. And the
idea that this amount of power is being given
to an unelected individual to set the agenda of
what is even going to be discussed and voted on
in the Senate, I my preference would be I know
the right will say, oh, it's authority. Look at
these Democrats in authority. My preference
would be overrule and replace is necessary.
Get these things debated, get Republicans on
the record, actually opposing them on the merits
if that's what they want to do. And let's
hold people accountable and actually try
to push for some of this stuff. And of
course, the cynical reaction would be,
you know, this is Democrats finding a way to
not have to have the debates about some of these
things that will split the party. And there's
probably validity to that. But I'm disgusted with
the parliamentarian stuff and I agree. Listen, I
on fifteen dollar minimum wage, I get the math of
it right. Even if you overrule the parliamentarian
and you put minimum 15 dollar minimum wage in
the covid bill, it doesn't pass. I get that. And
that's a specific situation. It's now just being
used as an umbrella when you you already may
not have all Democrats supporting the agenda.
So put this stuff in and let's actually get it to
the floor and debate this stuff. That's my view.
If you disagree with me, let me know. Join the
discussion at David Pakman Dotcom slash. Read it